poser une nouvelle question on vous
trouve l'info pour obtenir des dons les
organismes de bienfaisance nous bombarde
d'envois postaux paul legault et sa
conjointe n'en peuvent plus on donne ils
ont envoyé à notre recherchiste la
panoplie de lettres qu'ils ont reçu au
cours des derniers mois
[Musique]
certains organismes en bois toutes
sortes de cadeaux débat des stylos et
même de l'argent tout pour vous inciter
à donner
paul nous demandent comment faire pour
arrêter de recevoir toutes ses lettres
nous avons contacté une avocate d'option
consommateurs deux provinces vous
permettent de demander formellement de
retraite vos renseignements la colombie
britannique avec le personnel en
formation protection act et le québec
avec la loi sur la protection des
renseignements personnels dans le
secteur privé
mais une chose est sûre si vous
contenter de simplement retourner les
lettres à l'expéditeur
ça me donnera probablement pas grand
chose passés le mot
[Musique]